Alexa exciting day new deus ex mankind
divided trailer yes so excited it looks
freaking awesome uh yeah square knows
how to make a trailer they did was
really enjoyable let's break it down cuz
it's actually chock full of a lot of
stuff and interesting hints about what's
to come so let's start the end of human
Revolution you had to make a choice yeah
what is the beginning of this trailer
tell you about choice that you made so
you're floating in the water and it
looks like there's fire above you so we
can assume that Jensen went with the
choice to blow up the facility and let
humankind decide for themselves what
they want to do about augmentations so I
mean they did that with invisible wars
too so I mean I'm not really prized the
conflict that becomes clear pretty early
on is that people with augmentations are
being persecuted by the police they're
being rounded up and beat up and we see
for the first time this guy with the
yellow hoodie yeah my name is Ivan you
can see it in the later shot with TV
Ivan Burke and basically the trailer one
of the sort of through lines of the
trailer is the making of this guy as a
terrorist he's persecuted he's getting
his ass kicked by the police he finds a
charismatic leader to ally himself with
and then it's implied that he is the
bomber who creates the the destruction
we see ya
I think that focus on him means I think
he's gonna be main character I think
this is not the last 15 of Ivan and one
with Ivan the big scary Russian guy big
scary Russian guy yeah hey Russian guy
he is definitely gonna be he's obviously
we see him in the news he's a huge
character and he has he's sort of
defined by that old very bulky
augmentation style he's even got like
wires and stuff not the slick sort of
Adam Jensen sheriff industries he's old
guard yeah he's old garbage means he's
been around he's sort of suffered a lot
I always seen characters like this in
Deus Ex before Gunter and the first deus
ex was like kind of kind of a gnarly
looking dude because he was one of the
first one to get augmentations yeah I I
really liked that this is set in Prague
and we found out it was in prague by
zooming into that one screen yeah i
think the formation well there's the map
scene right when he's sort of it starts
off he's talking about we see if the
Illuminati is clearly back that imagery
of the hand on the globe which has been
seen in probably every deus ex game at
least human revolution on the original
and then the corporate logo some of
which I recognize some of which seem new
well what about that uh hit that sweet
jacket that he's wearing my sweet
acronym jacket like google that and it's
a actual clothing company that's crazy
like what it is it is that a thing it is
done like they're using real-world
brands but it's like 20 29 well square
enix is doing it with Final Fantasy 15
in coleman campaign so I'm kind of not
surprised to see a German clothing brand
in Deus Ex
so uh we actually saw quite a few
familiar faces in this trailer as well
yeah the newscaster Eliza kisan she's in
there saying terrorist attacks are
mounting across Europe and of course and
the end of human Revolution she was she
was totally connected with Adam Jensen
she like led him from place to place
sometimes and she he found out that
she's actually just an AI program oh
she's not an actual human and so she's
obviously gonna be a factor here if
she's still doing the news she's gonna
find out Adam Jensen still around yeah
and you know she was the one that even
presented him with that big choice at
the end of human revolution so I laid
out what's gonna happen for him but
that's not the only familiar face me
Simone no we saw Megan in a very sad
flashback of her being beaten brutally
to the ground harking back to Adam being
unable to save her in the beginning of
human revolution but uh spoilers
obviously for human revolution but
obviously if you're watching this you
should probably have played human
Revolution she's alive and working on
another project this is a trailer is
pretty heavy on the religious imagery
yeah the cyber hand going to touch the
human hand that's from that's like
voguing the creation of adam which is a
portion of the Sistine Chapel the
Michelangelo painted it's between God
and Adam in the image like God's hand is
where the cyber hand is and then the
dead corpse hand is Adams hand yeah so I
mean what does that say about where this
is going obviously it's you know cyber
augmented augmented people versus people
who have like meat hands is a big issue
there's even a like little campaign
poster you can see in the background
about the vote which will win so that's
obviously for conflict and always has
been for the series speaking of hands
and people there's like we've got a hand
face imagery as well we have our big
daddy and ivan is leaning down to kiss
his fingers oh yeah kiss the ring that's
like a total of the Catholic Church
thing I think they'd at least used to do
Kings
lean down to kiss ring as sort of yeah
absolutely pledge of fealty I am I also
noticed there are two shots not one but
two shots in the trailer in which Adam
Jensen has wings oh yeah 118 wigs one of
them is yellow one of them is sort of
blues that's like warm and cool also
that evokes that like Icarus and
Daedalus myths that had been talked
about a lot in Deus Ex yeah I was
applying too close to the Sun and
humanities hubris when it comes to
technology I really think that that sort
of imagery for this trailer going into
this game works well because in the
previous game they sort of left him they
left at him a little morally ambiguous
and there were a lot of choices that you
could make so I'm hoping that mankind
divided gives you as the player the same
kind of agency over his moral choices oh
yeah that would be cool Adam Jensen's
got a lot of cool ooh [ __ ] oh let's talk
about it dude office augmentations like
all the fighting scenes like that is one
of the combat in human Revolution was so
so entertaining and one of the things we
see very early on is the cloaking shield
like the invisibility situation which
gets him into combat starts to punch a
chickie the elbow blades come out shoot
them now yes and in once he does shoot
it so that's obviously very deadly
speaking of deadly his arm situation
what's going on there you gun so I get
multiple functions yeah it's like it
turns the earlier turns into like this
mega blaster which kind of looks like a
non-lethal thing it like knocks three
cops on their butts but then later on it
seems like it gets a little more desert
there's the Taser as well take it easy
people oh yeah knuckle tasers novel
tasers I was really interested by I sort
of towards the end of the trailer when
he's engaging in combat with big Russian
bad guy he charges up and then dashes
but also he does it from an elevated
balcony so one of the things I loved
about human Revolution
was the elevation changes and sort of
how you could use that and any of any
other tools that allow you to use the
environment more in combat are good with
me and then he has his shield oh yeah
wraps up Felix healed he wraps up by
turning into deus ex concept art
basically she better power turning it to
costco it just gets all triangle ified
and all of a sudden all those bolts come
to the way aren't gonna do as much
damage to him so so far mankind divided
looks like a good mix of old stuff in
new stuff yeah kinda yeah what we've
liked before maybe what we can look
forward to hopefully we'll see some more
maybe III mankind divided hoping
you